présentes dans la voiture, puis ont utilisé
des outils complexes de rétro-ingénierie
afin de déterminer ce que le logiciel faisait.
Ils ont trouvé des failles dans ce logiciel
puis ont développé des programmes exploitant ces failles.
Ils ont enfin réalisé leur attaque dans des conditions réelles.
Ils ont acheté deux voitures -- j'imagine
qu'ils ont de meilleurs budgets que moi.
La première expérience devait permettre de voir
ce qu'un hacker pouvait faire s'il accédait
au réseau interne de la voiture.
Imaginez : quelqu'un s'introduit dans votre voiture,
y bidouille quelque chose, puis s'en va.
Que risquez-vous désormais ?
La seconde expérience consiste à pirater la voiture
en temps réel par un réseau sans fil
-- comme celui de téléphonie mobile ou un autre --
sans jamais avoir besoin d'accéder physiquement à cette voiture.
Voici à quoi ressemblait leur installation dans le premier cas,
avec un accès à la voiture.
Ils ont utilisé un ordinateur portable qu'ils ont connecté à l'unité de diagnostic
du réseau interne de la voiture, puis ont fait toutes sortes de choses stupides
comme le montre cette image du compteur de vitesse
indiquant 220 km / h à l'arrêt.
Une fois qu'on a le contrôle sur les ordinateurs embarqués,
on peut faire ce qu'on veut.
Peut-être vous dites-vous : "Bon, ça c'est ridicule."
Mais qu'en serait-il si le compteur affichait systématiquement
la vitesse réduite de 30 km / h ?
Certainement un grand nombre d'amendes pour excès de vitesse.
Puis ils sont allés sur une piste d'atterrissage désaffectée avec deux voitures
-- une voiture cible et une voiture de poursuite --
et ont lancé plusieurs autres attaques.
Ils ont notamment réussi à actionner les freins
de la voiture cible depuis la voiture de poursuite,
simplement en piratant l'ordinateur de bord.
Ils ont aussi pu désactiver les freins.
Ils ont enfin réussi à installer un virus qui ne se déclenche
que lorsque la voiture effectue une action
comme dépasser les 30 km / h par exemple.
Les résultats sont stupéfiants, et même
quand ils les ont présentés lors d'une conférence
destinée à des chercheurs en sécurité informatique,
tous étaient stupéfaits.
Ils ont pu prendre le contrôle de plusieurs ordinateurs critiques
de la voiture : le contrôleur des freins, de l'éclairage,
du moteur, du tableau de bord, de la radio, etc.
Et ils ont pu faire cela sur des voitures
achetées dans le commerce, en les piratant par radio.
Ils ont réussi à compromettre
chacune des parties du logiciel qui contrôle
toutes les fonctions sans fil de la voiture.
Toutes ces attaques ont été couronnées de succès.
Comment ferait-on pour voler une voiture avec cette méthode ?
Eh bien, vous exploitez une faille de buffer overflow
dans le logiciel, ou quelque chose du genre.
Puis vous localisez la voiture à l'aide du GPS intégré.
À distance, vous ouvrez les portières en accédant
à l'ordinateur qui contrôle le verrouillage, vous démarrez le moteur, vous contournez l'antivol
et vous avez votre voiture.
Autre aspect très intéressant : la surveillance.
Les auteurs de l'étude montrent dans une vidéo
comment ils ont pris le contrôle d'une voiture,
ont allumé le micro embarqué pour écouter,
tandis que la voiture était pistée par GPS sur une carte,
et tout cela de manière à ce que les personnes à bord
ne se rendent compte de rien.
Déjà effrayés ?
En voici encore quelques-unes intéressantes.
Voici celles que j'ai découvertes lors d'une conférence ;
j'en suis tombé à la renverse, et je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que je le partage avec d'autres.
Le travail du laboratoire dirigé par Fabian Monrose
à l'université de Caroline du Nord
consiste à quelque chose d'intuitif
mais plutôt surprenant.
Ils ont filmé des personnes dans un bus
puis ont traité la vidéo en postproduction.
Ce que vous voyez là au numéro 1,
c'est la reflet du smartphone d'une personne
dans ses lunettes.
Ils ont écrit un programme pour stabiliser
-- même dans un bus
ou avec un certain angle de vue --
l'image du téléphone et la traiter.
Vous savez, quand vous entrez un mot de passe sur votre smartphone,
les touches sur lesquelles on appuie se mettent légèrement en surbrillance.
Ils ont pu utiliser cela pour reconstituer ce que l'utilisateur entrait,
et définir un modèle de langage pour détecter un texte tapé.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'en filmant dans un bus,
ils ont pu reconstituer exactement ce que les personnes
avaient tapé sur leurs smartphones.
Puis ils ont eu la surprise de constater
que leur logiciel l'avait fait non seulement pour la personne ciblée
mais également pour les autres personnes
apparaissant accidentellement sur la vidéo. Ils ont pu reconstituer
ce que ces personnes tapaient ; c'était une sorte d'effet
secondaire involontaire de leur logiciel.
Je vais vous en montrer encore deux. Tout d'abord, les radios P25.
Les radios P25 sont utilisées par la police
ainsi que toutes sortes d'agences gouvernementales
ou même les soldats au front, pour communiquer.
Ces téléphones possèdent une option d'encodage.
Voici à quoi ressemble ce téléphone. Ce n'est pas vraiment un téléphone,
plutôt un émetteur-récepteur.
Motorola produit le modèle le plus utilisé, et vous pouvez voir
qu'il est utilisé par les services secrets, par les soldats au front, etc.
C'est très commun aux États-Unis et ailleurs.
La question que se sont posée les chercheurs,
était : pourrait-on bloquer ces communications ?
Pourrait-on provoquer un déni de service
sur ces communications d'urgence ?
Est-ce qu'une organisation terroriste pourrait aveugler
les communications de la police et des pompiers lors d'une urgence ?
Ils ont découvert qu'un appareil de GirlTech permettant d'échanger des SMS
utilise exactement la même fréquence
que les radios P25 ; ils ont donc conçu ce qu'ils ont appelé
"Mon Premier Brouilleur". (Rires)
Si vous observez attentivement l'appareil,
il y a un interrupteur pour encoder ou non.
Laissez-moi passer à la diapositive suivante, puis revenir à celle-ci.
Vous voyez la différence ?
Ici on est en texte clair. Là, c'est encodé.
Il y a un petit point qui apparaît sur l'écran,
et un petit changement au niveau de l'interrupteur.
Les chercheurs se sont donc demandé
combien de fois des conversations très sensibles et importantes
sont transmises avec ces émetteurs-récepteurs
où l'option d'encodage a été oubliée sans que les interlocuteurs ne le remarquent.
Ils se sont donc procurés un scanner radio, un dispositif parfaitement légal aux États-Unis.
Ils l'ont utilisé à la fréquence des radios P25
et ont parcouru les fréquences environnantes
puis ont développé un logiciel d'écoute.
S'ils trouvaient une communication encodée, ils restaient
sur cette fréquence, en indiquant que cette fréquence
était utilisée par ces personnes pour communiquer,
ces agents de maintien de l'ordre.
Ainsi, ils sont allés dans 20 agglomérations et ont écouté
les conversations transmises sur ces fréquences.
Ils ont découvert que dans chacune de ces agglomérations
ils captaient plus de 20 minutes de communication
en clair par jour.
Et de quoi parlaient ces personnes ?
Eh bien, de noms et d'informations
concernant des informateurs ; d'informations
enregistrées lors d'écoutes téléphoniques ;
d'un certain nombre de délits examinés
et d'informations sensibles,
principalement policières et criminelles.
Ils l'ont signalé aux agences de maintien
de l'ordre, après avoir anonymisé les données.
La faille ici était simplement due à une mauvaise
interface utilisateur. Si vous êtes en train de discuter
de sujets sensibles qui doivent être sécurisés, il faudrait
que la conversation soit clairement indiquée comme encodée.
Cette faille est facile à corriger.
La dernière chose que je trouvais vraiment, vraiment génial,
je vais juste vous le montrer ; ça ne va sûrement pas
vous empêcher de dormir
comme les voitures ou les défibrillateurs.
Il s'agit de reconnaissance de frappe au clavier.
Les smartphones ont été étudiés sous toutes les coutures.
Tout expert en sécurité souhaite pirater un smartphone ;
on s'est intéressé au port USB, au GPS pour pister le téléphone,
à la caméra, au micro, mais personne jusque-là
ne s'est intéressé à l'accéléromètre.
L'accéléromètre est le composant qui détermine
l'orientation verticale du smartphone.
Ils ont donc mis au point une installation simple :
après avoir placé un téléphone à proximité d'un clavier,
ils ont demandé à des personnes de taper au clavier ; leur but était
d'exploiter les vibrations créées par la frappe des touches,
pour mesurer les changements de l'accéléromètre
permettant ainsi de déterminer ce que la personne écrit.
Avec un iPhone 3GS,
voici le graphe des perturbations créées
lors de la frappe : comme vous pouvez le voir, il est difficile
de déterminer quand quelqu'un écrit ou ce qu'il écrit ;
mais l'accéléromètre de l'iPhone 4 a été grandement amélioré,
et avec les mêmes mesures,
on obtient ce graphe.
Cela vous donne beaucoup d'informations quand quelqu'un
écrit quelque chose ; les chercheurs ont utilisé
des techniques avancées d'intelligence artificielle comme l'apprentissage automatique
afin d'établir une phase d'apprentissage.
Puis ils ont demandé certainement à des étudiants diplômés
d'écrire tout un tas de choses afin que le système puisse
-- grâce aux outils d'apprentissage automatique --
apprendre à reconnaître ce que les personnes écrivaient
et l'apparier
avec les mesures de l'accéléromètre.
Vient ensuite la phase d'attaque,
où quelqu'un écrit quelque chose que l'on ignore
mais grâce au modèle défini
par la phase d'apprentissage, on détermine ce qu'il écrit.
Leurs résultats étaient plutôt bons. Voici un article d'USA Today.
Il y est écrit : "La Cour Suprême de l'Illinois a décrété
que Rahm Emanuel a droit de se présenter au poste de maire de Chicago"
-- remarquez le lien avec la dernière conférence --
"et le somme de rester en lice."
Le système a un comportement intéressant : il a retrouvé
les deux premiers mots mais ensuite n'était pas certain.
Le modèle a donc proposé une liste de possibilités.
C'est là la beauté de certaines techniques d'intelligence artificielle :
les ordinateurs sont bons dans certains domaines,
les humains dans d'autres.
Il s'agit de choisir le meilleur des deux : ici l'humain.
Ne perdez pas de temps à faire calculer les ordinateurs.
Un être humain saura qu'il ne s'agit pas du Pouvoir Suprême
mais de la Cour Suprême, n'est-ce pas ?
Et ainsi, ensemble, nous sommes capables de retrouver ce qui est écrit
simplement en observant les mesures de l'accéléromètre.
Pourquoi est-ce important ? Eh bien, sur Androïd
par exemple, les développeurs ont un manifeste
sur lequel chaque dispositif -- le micro, etc. --
doit être déclaré si vous voulez l'utiliser :
ainsi les pirates ne peuvent en prendre le contrôle,
mais personne ne contrôle l'accéléromètre.
Quelle est l'idée derrière cela ? Vous pouvez laisser votre iPhone à côté
du clavier de quelqu'un, puis simplement quitter la pièce ;
plus tard, vous récupèrerez ce qui a été écrit,
même sans l'usage d'un micro.
Si quelqu'un parvient à installer une appli malveillante sur votre iPhone,
il pourrait peut-être récupérer ce que vous écrivez
lorsque vous laissez votre iPhone à côté de votre clavier.
Il y a pas mal d'autres attaques remarquables dont je n'ai
malheureusement pas le temps de parler, mais je voulais
attirer votre attention sur un groupe de l'Université du Michigan
qui ont pu récupérer des machines à voter,
des Sequoia AVC Edge DRE
qui allaient être utilisées lors d'une élection dans le New Jersey.
Ces machines étaient laissées dans le hall. Ils ont installé Pac-Man dessus.
Ils ont donc pu jouer à Pac-Man.
Qu'est-ce que tout cela signifie ?
Eh bien, je pense que notre société a tendance à adopter de nouvelles technologies
très rapidement. On est séduit par le prochain gadget génial.
Mais c'est très important, comme nous le démontrent ces chercheurs,
que les développeurs travaillant dans ce domaine
doivent prendre en compte la sécurité dès le début
et réaliser que malgré leur modèle de risques
les pirates n'auront peut-être pas la décence
de s'y limiter ;
il faut donc penser hors des chemins battus.
Nous pouvons prendre conscience
que tout dispositif peut être compromis,
et que tout ce qui comporte du logiciel
est susceptible d'être vulnérable. Il y aura forcément des bugs.
Merci beaucoup. (Applaudissements)